so i'm really excited because this is my
first live video i've ever done
on the channel live review i just
watched
the new wanda vision live with you guys
uh it's 3 a.m it starts here on the east
coast
so right now it's like almost four in
the morning but i
am super hyped to do this i had to do it
for this because
now we're actually getting into the
third act
of this show and you can see now clearly
that
it was broken up into three acts with
the first act
really being that wanda and vision
didn't really understand what was
happening and then
we got the middle patch of episodes
where they're slowly learning and then
we knew now with these next three we're
in the final act here
and that last episode we got vision and
wanda now
starting to really become aware of
what's going on but
there's a lot of feelings i have mixed
feelings about this episode because i've
loved
everything since episode four i really
like the first three but then this one
kind of brings me back
down a bit towards the first three area
it's still a little better than that but
i have a couple frustrations i think
first it has to be
with how they kind of handled darcy
lewis in this episode and her
relationship to vision in this episode
because
darcy was kind of annoyingly super
casual about
everything with vision here um because
the second vision brought her and
snapped her out of this
modern family mask here of darcy
she kind is just chill about everything
and
she continues being the plotbot of the
show just
it's such a simple transfer of
information for her to vision to just
kind of catch him up on everything so i
it felt a little lazy writing-wise and i
feel like
there still could have been more showing
and clever reveal to really finally hit
the nail into how vision would kind of
really get aware of everything because
he's pretty much there at this point and
then
i think the stronger side of this
episode clearly was with the wanda stuff
and the huge reveal at the end here
which has been theorized by a lot of
people about
agnes being agatha and it was agatha all
along i really like how it ended
on that with her saying and i killed the
dog sparky too
and what was really cool was that they
showed those quick little
clips from agatha's perspective and we
switched the focus now and her
putting all these illusions she can do
as a witch and
it was cool seeing her it showed she was
the director of the modern family style
and she was the one
that says literally to wanda do you
think it's what you deserve about what's
happening around her
that was like your big hint like who
said that and
it's been agnes and that was cool and
also as good they showed the scene from
last week where she
was like snapped out by vision but she
was only putting on an
act like she was fine the whole time she
just knew what to do there so
that's just classic witch villain type
stuff so i did like that reveal
obviously catherine hans the perfect one
to play a villain like that
i still hope though there's a bigger
villain even
bigger than agnes here that's still you
know everyone's got their theories about
what's going on with dottie we haven't
seen her in a couple episodes i think we
got a glimpse of her for a second here
but i still think there is one more
faction to this but it's really
interesting with agnes because
yeah you see her motivation about
constantly pushing
them having children was from the start
to get super powered
kids and that's there with billy and
tommy
and really interesting that billy says
to agnes you know it's basically all
just empty when he's like reading her
mind like what's up with that and that's
another hand like this is just this cold
witch here so
that was really cool and then we get now
with monica
everyone's kind of waiting for her to
get her super powers it's been hinted
now because she's already gone through
the hex twice so then
they do the space rover thing that just
fails
but she decides just going i really like
that sequence of her
running through the hex and then it's
like okay now she's really getting
these powers and it's gonna be
interesting because now it's gonna
put that protagonist of this story
monica
rambo to have a good kind of
power that she needed here to stand up
to wanda
and now she can help wanda like she's
wanted to
this whole time against this agnes type
who
has wanda in her trap in this basement i
love when they change the aspect ratio
of the frame here and that happens
when wanda is realizing what's going on
goes downstairs to like this witchy
layer
and agnes has the kids so that's an
exciting cliffhanger and
knowing now we only have two episodes
left and like i was saying like these
last three episodes is like the third
act of the show
story now they've really set up that i
believe
from what we've seen in the trailers
this moment where wanda's looking at the
infinity stone that we're gonna get this
flashback episode with wanda and what
kind of
fills in the spaces of what happened
with her how she came across
agatha maybe again ending next week with
an even bigger reveal
of there's another piece to this puzzle
and how this all really
became and happened but
i think knowing that that this was like
the modern family episode
then you go to next week where it's
gonna
probably be a flashback so you can have
time for the finale to
just be okay now it's resolving
everything climax
a lot of action so we'll see but
like i said i think that
there's things that really worked here
like the show's always worked but even
the beginning of this episode was really
dark stuff they were writing
with wanda and how she didn't really
care about anything the way she was
talking to her kids but
it was smart again how well they blend
and use the theme of let's say modern
family this episode
to just kind of cover it so it doesn't
look as bleak so
really just awesome on that part but i
do think this episode
kind of dragged its feet a bit
especially because
a lot of this information we already
kind of progressed last week
and i feel like like i said last week
was this big transitional episode in the
catalyst
to get things going now and i think this
one
really at the end of the day was just
monica getting her powers and she kind
of
knew was coming they kind of handed us
that and the agnes reveal you gotta you
know i
could feel like people could be a little
disappointed by it because it's been
predicted since literally episode one
but
we got to be careful because i think
everyone's just getting really good at
predicting stuff now and like i said
with the reddit community and all these
easter egg videos
you know it could take away a little bit
where i think you might have had a
better effect if you had no idea and
haven't watched any theories or
haven't watched any videos like that and
just let that soak in so i'm not going
to discredit that i think it's a really
cool reveal
um and i think there's obviously plenty
more to come
but this episode like i said the
frustrations something about the
darcy lewis scenes are just really just
you know run-of-the-mill again she's
giving you the exposition she's just
transferring stuff so these writers can
get certain information other people
and she was again like i said
frustratingly casual about the whole
experience where
you know this is her chance to talk to
the superhero envision
being an outsider and now she's not
under the influence anymore of modern
family or whatever the hecks
so it was like come on can she be a
little more serious about this they're a
little pushing
a vision but that didn't really happen
uh so that's when
i could tell like mc you can get a
little too quirky for my taste and i
think that's when it hurts it but
otherwise it's a really solid
installment i'm gonna give this episode
an 8.7 uh like i said
i think it's better than the first three
but it's the first one that i would say
is
not on that same tier that four five and
six have been but like i said i'm still
really excited
still really dug it and i can't wait for
the next episode which should be
uh flashback i'm guessing we'll see
though but let me know
know in the comments down below what you
guys thought of this episode and please
also let me know
if you like me doing this live review
version for wanda vision
so i can do it right when it drops or if
you prefer me to just
make a longer more detailed video and it
comes out a little later let me know
i really like to hear this kind of
experiment for me but um
yeah just let me know what you thought
of the show please subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of one
division i'm obviously do every single
episode i also review other shows
do celebrity interviews and please
follow me at steve barley show on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time